At exactly 6 AM on January 18th, 2014,
the sun began peeking above the horizon in
Luanda, Angola, marking the beginning of what
seemed, at the time, like any ordinary day.
Just seven nautical miles off
the coast sat anchored “Kerala”,
a Greek-owned, Liberian-flagged,
Angolan-chartered oil tanker.
Kerala had just loaded
60,000 metric tons of diesel
and was carrying a 27-person crew,
when something strange happened.
The ship suddenly stopped broadcasting a signal.
Its owner tried but failed to make contact.
As far as any map, satellite, or radar
was concerned, Kerala stopped existing.
An entire day went by… nothing. Then
another day. And another. Then five more.
Finally, on Sunday, January 26th,
eight days after its disappearance,
the tanker emerged 1,300 miles
north, off the coast of Nigeria.
It wasn’t hard to put the pieces together:
13,000 tonnes of oil, worth $8 million,
was missing, one crew member injured, and the
ship’s identification markers painted over.
In case there remained any doubt
that this was a clear case of piracy,
a suspicious tugboat had been sighted nearby.
Instead, the plot thickened…
Sponsored by Morning Brew — the free,
daily newsletter that keeps you up to
date on the world of tech and business.
When you hear the word “piracy”, you probably
think, consciously or otherwise, of Somalia.
For a long time, this was the
capital of maritime hijackings.
At its peak, in 2011, 736 crew members
and 32 ships were held hostage.
Why Somalia?
The answer seems obvious: The average person
lives just 57 years, and its GDP per capita
is the second-lowest of any country on earth.
It ranks at the bottom, in fact, of nearly
every metric where data is available.
But while most of the population lives
on less than one US dollar a day,
just a few miles off the coast pass by ships
carrying many millions of dollars in cargo.
To put things in perspective, Somali pirates
collected an estimated $70 million in 2009, which
would make it the country’s third most lucrative
industry, after Gold, and sheep and goats.
The actual cost of piracy, on the other hand,
is much larger. It includes not only the ransoms
themselves, but also the second-order costs of
prevention, insurance, and lost efficiencies.
When everything, from hired security to longer,
alternate routes are factored in, a single
hijacking, between Europe and Asia, increases the
overall maritime shipping costs that year by 1.2%.
Now, around 2009, the world
collectively decided enough was enough.
NATO’s Operation Ocean Shield was led
by the U.S., but everyone, from Norway,
to Pakistan, China, and even Russia pitched in.
It’s a strange set of circumstances
that gets India and Pakistan,
the U.S. and Russia, and China and Japan to
fight on the same side, but nobody likes pirates.
And, to the surprise of no one,
guided-missile destroyers and
their assortment of Seahawk helicopters were
victorious over… a few dozen wooden skiffs.
Since 2018, thanks to an aggressive
military response, both mercenary and naval,
no attacks have occurred in the
international waters around Somalia.
Piracy, it seemed, was
becoming a thing of the past.
Then, like a game of whack-a-mole,
it sprung up somewhere else.
This time on the other side of
Africa, around the Gulf of Guinea,
whose coastline stretches nearly
4,000 miles from Senegal to Angola.
Today, a staggering 95% of all global
kidnappings occur in these waters.
Eight of the nine ships fired upon in 2015
were traveling through the Gulf of Guinea.
In 2017, over a third of all
ships passing through the
region carried kidnapping and ransom insurance.
Although it hasn’t yet reached
the level of Somalia at its peak,
the Niger Delta is becoming
the new global piracy hotspot.
Half of Nigeria lives in what the
UN calls “multidimensional poverty”,
which measures both income, and other
factors like healthcare and education.
Wherever there’s poverty plus
opportunity, it seems, piracy will follow.
Yesterday, Somalia. Today, Nigeria.
And tomorrow, somewhere else.
Or, so it appears, on the surface. In reality,
what we’ve come to think of as “piracy”, is more
a result of specific circumstances within Somalia
than the explanations Hollywood popularized.
Piracy in each region is
based on entirely different,
culturally and economically
distinct, business models.
The central problem facing the country of
Somalia is that… it’s hardly a country, at all.
Since the collapse of a centralized government in
1991, Somalia has been ruled by regional fiefdoms
with varying degrees of law and order.
Over the course of one 16 year period,
no fewer than 14 failed attempts were made
to establish a new national government.
The result is that, while most of the world
recognizes only one sovereign “Somali state”,
there are, in effect, several self-proclaimed
independent governments and warlords.
One of which, Somaliland, acts, in practice, like
any other nation — issuing its own passports,
holding its own elections,
and enforcing its own customs.
This inability by the central government to
project power beyond the capital, combined with
droughts, and aggravated by insurgents, means
that a general lawlessness pervades the region.
The resulting unemployment is one
of the primary drivers of piracy,
yet, Somalis have simultaneously
turned this into a strategic advantage.
Anyone, anywhere in the world armed with an
AK-47 and some bravery can attack a ship,
most of which really only travel
at 20 or 25 miles an hour.
The problem is what you do after that. The most
valuable cargo on a ship is its crew — from
which you can potentially extract anywhere from
700,000 to nearly 10 million dollars in ransoms.
But kidnappings are no walk in the
park. Fresh-faced pirates are promised
action and adventure but soon discover
they’re more like small business owners.
Just as new franchisees realize all they’ve
done is paid for the right to flip burgers,
being a pirate isn’t all it’s cracked up to be.
Most of the job is spent transporting,
guarding, and feeding hostages,
doing bookkeeping, and,
above all… patiently waiting.
For every one person holding a gun
announcing “I’m the captain now”,
there’s at least one more doing
the boring, grunt work on-shore.
During the heyday, many coastal communities were
based entirely around supporting this “industry”.
The average length of a
kidnap-for-ransom operation
is 6 months, and some negotiations
drag on for over a year.
That’s six whole months of just
waiting, trying not to get caught.
But herein lies Somalia’s advantage.
Its complete and utter lack of formal
institutions — a motivated police force
or functioning government — means that
its pirates can afford to hold hostages as long
as necessary without fear of being found out.
Then there’s West Africa.
The region’s economic center is Nigeria, by
far the most populous country on the continent.
Nigeria is an oil giant. Its over 600 fields
pump out 2 million barrels of crude oil a day.
The industry generates 95% of the country’s
foreign exchange and 80%
of its budgetary revenues.
Yet, in a classic case of the “Resource Curse”,
only about a quarter of its
oil is refined domestically.
The rest is shipped abroad, refined, and
returned in an expensive and inefficient cycle.
To avert protest against a system
that clearly benefits only faraway
corporations and corrupt local politicians,
oil imports are heavily subsidized — making
its fuel among the cheapest in the world.
Corruption, resource dependency,
and exploitation mean that, despite
producing more oil than anywhere else in Africa,
Nigerians lack reliable access to electricity,
instead spending $9 million a
year on fuel for generators.
On top of all this, oil importers regularly
decide they aren’t getting properly compensated,
cut off supply, and create
shortages across the country.
The result is unmet demand for fuel
and a pervasive sense of injustice.
It’s hard to feel constrained by the law
when it’s abundantly clear that no one,
from local administrators
to top officials do either.
One way this manifests is
illegal, makeshift oil refineries.
A group of… “entrepreneurs” will set-up camp
in the swamp, burn crude oil in open air pits,
and sell whatever comes out the other
end at gas stations across the country.
The other way is known as “petro-piracy”,
an extension of the widespread plunder
of oil that occurs on rivers and
pipelines across the Niger Delta.
Unlike in Somalia, where most
pirate attacks are kidnappings,
a significant number here are
oil seizures targeting tankers.
In 2016, pirates stole 400,000 barrels of crude
oil every single day in the Gulf of Guinea,
for a total loss of $750 million in 2019 alone.
Ironically, part of Nigeria’s
problem is the opposite of Somalia’s.
Where Somali piracy flourished
in the absence of a state,
piracy in the Gulf of Guinea
is often enabled by it.
Put another way: its problem is that
it has too strong a formal economy
and not enough lawlessness.
Recall the case of Kerala. Logistically,
it would’ve been difficult to hide a ship
of that size for months at a time,
as was often done around Somalia.
On the other hand, some semblance
of formal institutions and markets
are an asset for Nigerian pirates — there’s
always an unscrupulous buyer for stolen oil.
Petro-piracy is sophisticated. For starters,
it happens really fast — sometimes oil is
seized and re-sold in a matter of hours,
quickly and untraceably moving between
the 20 countries in the Gulf of Guinea.
Attacks often require insider
information, connections, and planning.
Some studies suggest there’s
a kind of “sweet spot” between
anarchy and order that maximizes
opportunities for piracy.
After a ransom was successfully paid for MV
Victoria, a freighter attacked around Somalia
in 2009, for instance, pirates offered
to stay on board until it reached safety
to ensure it wasn’t hijacked by a competing gang.
Similarly, when al Qaeda tried to set up shop in
Somalia during the 90s, it was frustrated by its
lack of policing. Self-protection is costly and
time-consuming, even for pirates and terrorists.
When Kerala was eventually found, the
Angolan Navy conducted an investigation.
Its verdict? The whole episode
was faked. There was no hijacking,
and the suspicious tug was, instead, a “replica”.
What this means is either that someone on
the ship itself coordinated the attack,
or the Angolan government dismissed evidence
of what would be the most Southern attack in
the Gulf of Guinea at the time, worrying that
it would deter shippers and harm the economy.
As you can see, the lines between
the formal and informal economies,
and the “good” and “bad” guys are blurred and
sometimes even change from one day to the next.
The lesson, if there is one, is that stamping
out piracy once and for all is nearly impossible.
Take the case of Somalia. While it’s
true that the robust, multilateral
naval response was indeed effective, it
wasn’t quite as successful as it may seem.
Rather than disappearing overnight, pirates
and nearby ships, especially fishing vessels,
reached a sort of mutual agreement: Pay us for
a “fishing license” and you won’t be disturbed.
Nigerians, likewise, conveniently,
though at times convincingly,
argue that oil companies, who profit from
but give very little back to the country,
are the real pirates — extracting value
from the land for the benefit of few.
As long as these fundamental inequalities remain,
piracy will only adapt in its outward appearance
— moving on land and changing in name.
…One thing that hasn’t changed much is
how we get our news. I can spend hours
scrolling through Reddit and Twitter and not
really remember anything. Today’s sponsor,
Morning Brew is a better way to stay up to date
on the world of tech, business, and finance.
What I like about Morning Brew is that it’s
self-contained. There’s a start and an end,
not an infinite scroll. Every issue is
interesting, witty, and condensed, so
you can feel accomplished, up-to-date, and learn
something new in the first 10 minutes of your day.
In a recent Morning Brew, for example, I
learned that Amazon today has double the
number of employees it did at the start of 2020.
Amazingly, it also makes more revenue
from advertising than YouTube!
Click the link on-screen or in the description now
to sign up for the Morning Brew newsletter 100%
completely free and in just 15 seconds.
Sign up, give it a try, and thanks again
to Morning Brew for sponsoring this video!